so it is time to take a dive into
poolside entertainment at the
cosmopolitan of las vegas
rocky is live at their boulevard pool
getting a preview of the new summer
poolside events and experiences
and this one i hear will keep you
entertained and swimsuit ready rocky
yes exactly mercedes anna this is our
yogurt instructor she's the yoga
instructor of the cosmopolitan no big
deal
but we said this is going to keep you
entertained and also swimsuit ready
correct
so the goal of these classes this summer
everybody's coming out of quarantine
hoping to find something to do that's
good for their bodies so
the summer series is a way for our
guests and even biggest locals
to rejuvenate and reignite their bodies
for the summer absolutely it is called
the
the sweat 60 summer series nailed it
alliteration we love it okay
so what are the moves you do because you
said you you really like to cater to
people who are traveling too because
they need a lot of stretching they've
been
you know walking a lot right correct
yeah they usually are coming off of
planes or cars
so the class style that we do combines
yin and ashtanga
to help them build strength but also
stretch okay and relax
all right show me the move the posture
that we're doing today is called
parsvottanasana
it's also known as pyramid okay so i
have two versions for you okay
first one is if your balance compromise
if that's a little tricky for you
all right so step here in front of
spreading your blocks don't judge me
guys it's been a while with your left
leg
just take a wide step back oh okay okay
so this so while we're in class yes what
what are we enjoying obviously as you
can see behind me the pool is popping
everybody's enjoying got cocktail hour
here as well that started this week
we've got dive in movies on the big
screen that's right
it's so much fun and that's right yoga
classes start on june
4th they're happening on june 4th every
first and third friday of
the month all the way through september
17th so guests just need to pay
25 they'll get a towel a yoga mat as
well as a water
that's awesome and we register online on
our website
okay perfect and the cosmopolitan of las
vegas dot com correct
all right let's show let's show them the
move you guys get on get on the floor if
you're at home in your living room
so press through the toes of this right
foot okay and just hinge over the hips
see if you can't straighten that front
leg
good job straightening uh-huh oh my gosh
a little more of a stretch there this is
actually hurting because i need this
stretch good good
and then you'll come back up and tell us
the benefits tell us the benefit so this
posture
is meant to strengthen and stabilize not
only your core
but also your legs which i'm sure you
realized very quickly a moment ago
so let's do the second version just take
your hands out to the teeth uh-huh we've
got 10 seconds elbows in
back hands on the hips take a wide step
back oh
okay we are stretching poolside here at
the cosmopolitan the boulevard
pool it is beautiful up here the iconic
rooftop come on down the summer time
poolside experiences start now i will
send it back to you mercedes
thank you rocky i'm trying to do those
stretches with you that's uh that's a
during the 4pm newscast